two state elections last night gives him
20/20 clues President Trump goes after
Joe Biden and the media take off the
mask
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show oh man we have tons to get to on
today's show but first let me remind you
that tonight the latest stop on my young
America's Foundation speaking tour
brings me to Loyola Marymount University
where some of the professor's are pretty
ticked that I'm coming this speech
begins at 7:00 p.m. so get there early
bring a friend and as always brings some
great questions and may be sold out if
you can't make it tonight no problem you
can also watch the speech online at yah
org slash live it is all new material
for more information on my tour schedule
head on over to yah org slash Shapiro
tor that's Y after org slash Shapiro 2
or hope to see you there okay we're
going to get to the news in just one
second first let's talk about safety and
security in your community you've heard
me talk about how ring is reinventing
home security with doorbells and cameras
even an alarm you can install yourself
well they've now reinvented the
neighborhood watch with a new app they
created called neighbors by ring you
remember the neighborhood watched it
around for a while I remember it growing
up as a bunch of folks who were sort of
associated and would just keep an eye on
the neighborhood make sure that
everybody knew where the crime was
happening well the neighbors app is like
the new neighborhood watch on your phone
people taking stuff off porches trying
to or Nobbs late at night missing dogs
the neighbors app sends real-time
notifications to your phone whenever one
of your neighbors posts a heads-up about
something that's going on it does keep
you informed the neighbors app by ring
it's completely free anyone can join
even if they do not own a ring device
I've actually downloaded it myself from
the app store cuz I'm definitely
concerned about security in my
neighborhood I put in my address and set
the area around my home for a couple of
miles because I really only care what's
happening within those two miles and I
could see all of the local crime that
was happening people reporting exactly
what was happening so you know if
there's a risk that yeah there's been a
burglary in the neighborhood or
something like that you got to check out
the neighbors app yourself the easiest
way to get going is ring comm /sh appear
o ring.com /a Pierrot make your
neighborhood safer today with the
neighbors app by ring go check it out
right now
ring com forward slash Shapiro that's
ring comm forward slash appear actually
saw a video of somebody unscrewing the
gas pipe at somebody's house in trying
to steal natural gas I mean this is la
man go check it out right now
ring com forward slash appear you can
check out the neighbors happen you don't
even have to join ring into it Nate ring
comm /up hero okay so last night there
were a couple of local elections now as
you know there's a national show we
don't tend to put too much stock in
local elections or focus too much on
local
elections but in the lead up to 2020
everybody is looking for early
indicators for how things are gonna
split and it's funny when we talk about
presidential elections we tend to talk
in national terms obviously we tend to
say that President Trump is gonna win X
percent of the popular vote or Kamala
Harris if she were the nominee would win
an x percent of the popular vote the
reality is that this election is going
to come down to about three states it's
gonna come down to Wisconsin
Pennsylvania Michigan that's pretty much
it the assumption is the president Trump
is gonna walk away with Ohio that
assumption seems to hold pretty true
Florida is more competitive if he loses
Florida the election is over so assuming
that Trump wins Florida and that he wins
Ohio then he still has to win two out of
the three Michigan Pennsylvania or
Wisconsin in order for him to retain the
presidency and the kind of conventional
wisdom had been that Trump was going to
continue to be competitive in Michigan
and that in Pennsylvania he was still
somewhat competitive but that in
Wisconsin he was starting to fall off
and the evidence for this is that the
2018 elections move Wisconsin into more
blue territory well last night there was
a special election in Wisconsin for the
Wisconsin Supreme Court now the
Wisconsin Supreme Court is not an
overtly partisan seat it's not like
somebody runs as a Republican or a
Democrat for the actual Wisconsin
Supreme Court but those candidates are
backed by conservative groups or liberal
groups and last night the conservative
won in Wisconsin ensuring that Wisconsin
Supreme Court would remain majority
conservative for the foreseeable future
because now instead of things being four
to three on that Supreme Court and and
ready to shift in a moment's notice in
now conservatives have a 5-2 majority on
the Wisconsin Supreme Court and not only
that turnout was high and what the
election showed is that well there were
certain districts where trump has fallen
off a little bit particularly in
suburbia in rural areas he continues to
dominate according to according to
madison.com they report that the
conservative is winning by a very small
margin it may go to an automatic recount
but the Wisconsin Supreme Court race the
liberals needed to win to have a shot at
taking majority control of the court
next year I appeared headed for a
recount with the Conservative candidate
declaring victory while holding a narrow
lead following Tuesday's election the
conservative candidate is up over five
thousand votes a conservative win would
increase their majority to 5-2 and
ensure their control over the court
which they've held since 2008 for years
to come it would be a particularly
stinging defeat
for liberals who were confident and
riding a wave of wins in 2018 including
picking up a Supreme Court seat and
ousting Republican governor Scott Walker
conservative Bryan Hagedorn who was
Walker's chief legal counsel for five
years led liberal backs at Lisa Newbauer
by 59 hundred votes out of 1.2 million
cast based on the unofficial results
that difference of about 0.49 percentage
points is close enough for Neubauer to
request a recount but she would actually
have to pay for it so maybe it happens
maybe it doesn't hack adorns declared
victory early Wednesday morning this is
an electoral surprise minutes after he
declared victory the new banner campaign
sent out a fund raising plea saying that
would devote total neck-and-neck it
looks like we're headed to eight
potential recounts counties will canvass
the votes starting next week to
determine the official margin of victory
the last time there was a recount and a
Wisconsin Supreme Court race was in 2011
this this was the only statewide
election of the year so this is the only
bellwether that we have this year and
turnout was really strong in fact it was
a lot stronger than it was in 2018
Republicans showed up in 2018 they
showed up in bigger numbers in 20 in
2019 27 percent turnout for Wisconsin's
Supreme Court seat the tight outcome
provides more evidence as madison.com
of how evenly divided Wisconsin is
president Trump you'll remember carried
the state by less than one percentage
point Walker lost it by just over one
percentage point so this state is
basically dead even Hagedorn is victory
in battleground America sends a quote
message to all of America that we're
ready to keep Wisconsin red as we turn
our attention to mobilizing for 2020 and
reelecting president Trump's had mark
Jefferson the executive director of the
Wisconsin Republican Party so this is
it's a pretty astonishing result I mean
she was heavily favored the the liberal
in this race was heavily favored to take
the seat Eric hold her had it had an
outside group that was spending almost a
third of a million dollars - more than a
third of a million dollars actually to
help neubauer win they're a bunch of
conservative groups including Americans
for Prosperity that matched Democratic
outside spending Hagedorn spent much of
his race defending his conservative
beliefs Neubauer by contrast was
appointed to the appeals court in 2007
by a former Democratic governor and the
term there is 10 years and the retiring
Justice is 85 years old and a liberal so
this is a move in the direction of
conservatives
in Wisconsin now if you actually look at
the Wisconsin polls for 2020 president
what you see is president from
continuing to run relatively relatively
even with all of the other Democrats so
that is not true particularly for Joe
Biden I can give you some of the latest
polls from Wisconsin which again if
Trump were to win Wisconsin the odds
that he wins the election are very good
if he loses Wisconsin then the odds
obviously decline dramatically against
Joe Biden
according to Emerson College poll from
March 17th 2019 so a couple of weeks ago
Joe Biden would beat President Trump 54
to 46 according to a firehouse
strategies poll from a little bit later
couple days later Biden would beat Trump
pretty badly 53 to 40 but if you look at
him versus the other candidates it's
pretty much dead even Trump versus
Kamala Harris according to Emerson
College that is a 50/50 vote Trump
versus Amy Klobuchar from Minnesota that
is a 50/50 vote if you look at Trump and
bado o'rourke NATO has a slight
advantage but not much according to
Emerson only 51 49 the margin of error
is three point five so effectively that
is a dead even race Trump vs. Bernie
Sanders fifty two Sanders forty eight
Trump but again it's it's kind of far
out and that is effectively a dead even
race considering a margin of error of
three point five points with Donald
Trump and Elizabeth Warren Warren runs
away with it
according to Zogby but he's only up 52
to 48 according to Emerson so
effectively Trump is still running very
competitively in Wisconsin right now
unless the Democrats get smart and runs
somebody who is perceived as moderate
and has blue-collar appeal now that's
what makes it so interesting that the
Democrats have decided to go after Joe
Biden who it's pretty obvious from all
the polls is the most electable Democrat
for the 2020 race and that's not just in
Wisconsin last night there was another
there's another local race in
Pennsylvania and it was won by a
Democrat named Pam Iovino she won a
pennsylvania senate seat well the reason
that she won is because like Connor lamb
in Pennsylvania she is a veteran she is
a more Blue Dog Democrat type according
to the Post Gazette the last time Pam
Iovino was subject to a high stakes vote
tally was 2004 and she was unanimously
confirmed to lead the Department of
Veterans Affairs a congressional and
legislative affairs offices on Tuesday
the Democrat a Navy vet
was elected to the Pennsylvania State
Senate besting Republican D Raja in a
special election after a bruising
two-month campaign that garnered
national attention along the way during
the race Iovino who's 62 told voters in
the 37th district that her two decades
plus in the Navy and subsequent stints
in the executive branch would make her
the right fit for the legislature in the
district spanning Allegheny County's
western and southern suburbs and Peters
Township a majority of voters endorsed
that message at the poll the election
which was expected to be close and
possibly decided by a few hundred votes
was officially decided when Raja
conceded to misty Aveeno by phone and
around 9:30 p.m. she's about four
thousand votes ahead with 94% of the
precincts counted at the time so it's a
big win for Democrats in the state of
Pennsylvania but the point is that she
is a lot more conservative than a lot of
the Democrats that are being talked
about for the 2020 election cycle so she
has talked about greater focus on
workforce training for example she says
that she's gonna fight to alleviate the
property tax burden by making
corporations pay their fair share
she says that she is going to to focus
in on taxing natural gas drilling right
these are sort of Blue Dog Democrat
positions she didn't focus in on social
issues she didn't focus in on race
instead she focused in on sort of
bread-and-butter Democrat issues and she
won what does this say from what this
says that Democrats are gaining momentum
in some of the suburbs the president
from carried in 2016 but only but only
if Democrats are not stupid and run
people who are perceived as moderate as
I mentioned Iovino is a veteran she was
commissioned a Navy ensign in 1980 she
worked her way up to lieutenant and then
she took over as the first female
commander at Toledo's naval and marine
corps reserve center she was nominated
by George W Bush to her post on Capitol
Hill she ran against Connor Lam for the
Democratic nomination he went on to win
that congressional seat and both of the
you know both of the candidates went
after each other
hammer and tongs but Iovino did not run
as a hardcore
a hardcore Left Democrat she ran as a
moderate Democrat and that is why she
won and this is the point the Democrats
seem to have misread the map here they
seem to believe that what is popular in
San Francisco is popular in Alleghany
or in Wisconsin they seem to think that
if they run somebody who is really
extreme or who's intersectional on the
merits that that person is going to
suddenly sweep through all of the areas
that President Trump won in 2020 this
kind of indicates that you should shift
2020 back to toss-up lane now I've been
saying for a while that I slightly favor
Democrats in 2020 his president Trump
lost the popular vote by two and a half
million and he ran the narrowest
gauntlet in presidential history winning
three states by a combined total of
80,000 votes in an election against one
of the most unpopular people in the
history of American politics a person
who's expected widely to win I said you
can't count on Democrats not showing up
again that's true it is also true that
if Democrats veer too far in the left
direction they could easily lose some of
these purple states especially these
blue-collar purple states who are
looking at folks like beta or orch or
Kamala Harris and they're saying really
like this this is this is what you've
decided to put up that's what makes it
so entertaining that the Democrats seem
to believe they have this / yeah I'm not
sure whether it's driven by a perception
of invincibility or just pure anger what
they are doing in the Democratic
primaries right now I'll explain in just
one second first let's talk about the
best gift that you can get somebody
this year I'm talking of course about
legacy box now I'm a big believer that
the thing that matters most in your life
particularly is get older is making sure
that you have all your memories
preserved and you've got in your garage
all those boxes of old photos that you
haven't looked at in 30 years and
they're motoring out there some of them
are getting waterlogged and ruined and
if God forbid there are a fire some sort
of flood in your house you have to go
out to the garage and schlep those boxes
into a van instead of doing all that
stuff why don't you just go over to
legacy box save your family films and
photos from degrading or being lost
forever
it'll give you peace of mind a great
sense of accomplishment you can send
your legacy box filled with old home
movies and pictures and then legacy box
does the rest they professionally
digitized your moments onto a thumb
drive a digital download or a DVD which
is fantastic that means that you have
access to this stuff at all times and if
god forbid something should happen to
your garage well you don't have to worry
about all those boxes filled with photos
because you've already had it all
digitized legacy box is the world's
largest most trusted digitizer of home
movies and photos that's also because
they will personalize email updates to
you every step of the way so you make
sure that everything is being taken care
of properly
over 450,000 families that trusted
legacy box there's never been a better
time to digitally preserve those
memories visit legacy box comm today get
started plus for a limited time they're
offering my listeners an exclusive
discount go to legacy box comm slash Ben
get 40% off your first order Nets legacy
box comm slash Ben's say 40% today
legacy box comm slash Ben get 40% off
your first order it's a great gift a
meaningful gift something I think that
is really useful
legacy box comm slash Ben hey so as I
say I'm not sure where they're Democrats
right now are driven by hope or whether
they are driven by fear so here's the
argument for hope the argument for hope
is that President Trump is so deeply
unpopular that they can push as far left
as they possibly want and win an
election that they can reconstitute the
Obama 2012 coalition that intersectional
coalition and sweep to victory by
ignoring all the people who voted for
President Trump and then they can push
on with their Medicare for all high tax
high spend slavery reparations agenda
that this is it this is the push that
they can make because they've misread
the room and they think that Trump is
inherently so unpopular that they can
legitimately throw crap against the wall
and see what sticks
that is possibility number one
possibility number two is that they have
Bevin been driven so mad by President
Trump that they're sort of like
Republicans circa 2016 we want to
nominate the person who's gonna get on a
stage and Club President Trump we want
the person who's gonna be the most
aggressive on a stage with President
Trump now if that were the case then you
would sort of assume that Elizabeth
Warren would be doing better because
she's probably the most aggressive
Democrat in the field when it comes to
yelling at President Trump some of the
other Democrats who are who are doing
well right now
you know people like like Joe Biden
that's really not his bag you've seen it
from Bernie Sanders a little bit but it
seems to me that if I had to put my
money on it I would think the Democrats
have just misread the unpopularity of
Trump they think because he's at 42% in
the polls when it comes to popularity
rating that this somehow means that he's
only gonna win 42 percent of the vote
come 2020 and that of course is deeply
inaccurate and as we are seeing in
Wisconsin as we are seeing in
Pennsylvania Republicans are still gonna
vote Republican the great lie of 2016 is
that Donald Trump wildly outperformed
Republican expectations that is not true
he performed almost exactly in line with
how george w bush performed in all of
the swing states almost exactly in line
with how mit romney performed in all of
the swing states including Wisconsin
well Romney one more absolute votes than
Donald Trump did is just nobody showed
up to vote for Hillary Clinton in 2016
so Trump is going to continue to perform
like Generic Republican the question is
does Democrat perform like Generic
Democrat or does Democrat perform like
Barack Obama who was in fact a
statistical outlier Democrats seem to
believe that the world shifted on the
taxes when Obama was elected and that
there was a permanent majority created
for them forever
Trump disabuse them of that notion if
they rely on that permanent majority and
simply swing to the left in the belief
that they've got this thing locked up
they're making an awful awful mistake I
think that's one of the things lying
behind the attacks on Joe Biden so let's
move on to to Joe Biden so Joe Biden
continues to fall under brutal attack
from members of his own party apparently
two more women are now coming forward
and talking about how Joe Biden is a bit
of a creeper again it is amazing to me
to watch as the Democrats suddenly
discover something that has been in
plain sight we were making fun of this
for years the idea of handsy Joe Biden
Uncle Joe creepy Uncle Joe this was a
meme on the right for I kid you not
at least at least the last six to seven
years there is nothing new here I mean
Joe Biden was famous for going into
diners and putting women on his lap he
was famous for I mean I can't tell you
how many times I've seen that photo of
him leaning over to kiss the little girl
and the little girl shying away well now
there are several women who are coming
forward and saying he made them feel
uncomfortable
according to msn.com no prominent
Democrat has suggested that Biden not
run the women complaining about him have
not claimed sexual harassment or assault
other women have stepped forward to say
mr. Biden's touches were welcomed but
the accusations lodged against Biden
have raised questions about when a
tactile politician crosses the line into
inappropriateness
that's the Washington Post's description
I love that he's a tactile politician
you mean he creepily touches people in a
way that he should not if you were not a
creepy person and overly physical with
people
tactile politician gotta love that Nancy
Pelosi said that she didn't think it was
disqualifying but she also recommended
that he used the straight arm the
straight arm system wor'i'a Steinem said
politicians need to set the parameters
the way out is simple our bodies and our
voices belong to us that should be the
first step in democracy just ask before
hugging which by the way I don't think
is wrong but I'm finding it funny
that now Democrats are discovering all
of this after ripping on Mike Pence for
basically saying I would like to remove
myself from possibly fraught situations
in general a president Trump went after
Joe Biden because he understands there's
vulnerability here so here's Trump last
night at the NRCC apparently speaking in
front of the same bush in which Homer
Simpson is hiding here is President
Trump going after Joe Biden I mean Trump
as stand-up comedian is is pretty solid
Trump I said general can you give me a
kiss I felt like Joe Biden our former
vice president he's I was gonna call him
I don't know him well I was gonna say
welcome to the world Joe you have it a
good time Joe are you having a good time
okay well then that last line there by
it by Trump is not unearned Joe Biden
has been one of the chief and one of the
chief pushers of the idea that an
accusation is tantamount to a conviction
now the fact is that that Biden has been
doing this sort of stuff with regard to
harassment for a very long time
according to Casey Johnson over at the
New York Post according to the standards
of culpability that Biden has
articulated in similarly conflicted
situations all of this is an
open-and-shut case perhaps no major
American political figure has so
consistently championed the erosion of
due process for those accused of sexual
misconduct
he's championed this approach for
accused college students as the Obama
administration used a title mine to
impose guilt tilting procedures on the
nation's campuses until 2016
high-ranking administration officials
consistently refused to provide much if
any explanation and why they imposed a
preponderance of evidence standard as
opposed to a beyond a reasonable doubt
standard when it came to convicting men
of sexual harassment Biden has been the
most outspoken senior Obama official to
defend these policies in 2017 he framed
campus sexual assault as a problem
consisting solely of male attackers and
female victims he used an interview with
Teen Vogue to give a hypothetical
address to fraternity members quote if
you see a brother taking a drunk
freshman co-ed up the stairs to his room
and you do nothing you're a coward you
know that she's not able to give consent
he responded with fury to Secretary of
Education
Betsy devathas attempts to create fairer
procedures for adjudicating campus
sexual assault claims he called people
like DeVos cultural
Neanderthals okay so Joe Biden this is
not I it looks for this way it is not
uncalled for the Joe Biden is now being
held to a standard that he has that he
has pervade against others with that
said the Democrats coming out of the
woodwork to attack Biden are generally
not doing so in my opinion out of pure
worry for the women apparently there are
a couple other women who now say that
that Biden made them feel uncomfortable
Caitlin Caruso is a former college
student and sexual assault survivor she
said Biden rested his hand on her thigh
even as she squirmed in her seat she
showed her discomfort and hugged her
just a little bit too long at an event
on sexual assault at the University of
Nevada Las Vegas she was 19 Caruso now
22 said she talked chalked up the
encounter at the time to Hellman Act and
didn't say anything publicly she said it
was particularly uncomfortable because
she had just shared her own story of
sexual assault and had expected Biden to
understand the importance of physical
boundaries it doesn't even really cross
your mind that such a person would dare
perpetuate harm like that she said these
are supposed to be people you can trust
another woman came for DJ hill 59 a
writer who were called meeting Biden in
2012 at a fundraising event in
Minneapolis she said that when she and
her husband Robert stepped up to take
their photograph with the VP he put his
hand on her shoulder and then started
dropping it down her back which made her
very uncomfortable her husband seeing
the movement put his hand on mr. Biden
shoulder and interrupted with a joke
he'll does not say anything at the time
and acknowledged she did not know what
Biden's intention was or whether he was
aware of her discomfort only he knows
he's in his intent she said but norms
are changing now she said and if
something makes you feel uncomfortable
you have to be able to say it now of
course other women have come out and
defended Joe Biden that would include
Stephanie Carter the wife of ash Carter
who is saying all of this but what is
under grinning a lot of this is that the
more radical members of the Democratic
Party want Biden go on and the more
moderate members want Biden to stay
there's a lot of politics to the
situation so joe Manchin who was one of
the more moderate Democrats presumably
will be a Biden supporter if he declares
the senator from West Virginia he says
wasn't I've never seen anyone actually
offended by Biden I mean come on I can
tell you I've been around Joe Biden for
many many years I've been in many
political events with Joe Biden I have
never seen Joe Biden intentionally make
anybody uncomfortable if anything he
goes out of his way trying to make
people comfortable he thinks that might
be in a difficult situation that might
have had some concerns and has a lot on
him I've seen that compassion in Joe now
what Joe has said and I accept that the
same as I hope everyone does if he's
made anybody uncomfortable he's
extremely sorry for that I would hope
they would accept that okay so this this
sort of gap you can see it
between the the older guard members of
the Democratic Party who wish to
preserve the candidacy of Joe Biden and
the newer guard who are looking to get
him out so this would be include
representative Hakeem Jeffries one of
the younger members of Congress he came
out and he said these are very serious
allegations
even though let's be real about this the
allegations are not either unexpected or
particularly serious well these are
serious allegations they've been raised
by serious individuals and they deserve
a serious evaluation as to how Joe Biden
should proceed but that's a decision
that he needs to make on his own okay so
all of the younger members of the
Democratic Party are trying to push Joe
Biden out and it's fascinating how
they're doing this it's fascinating how
they're doing this again is in overreach
this is them overeating overeating the
results of 2012 rather than looking at
the nature of politics on the ground
we'll get to more of that in just one
second first let's talk about the fact
that it's already April time has a habit
of getting away but if you've got a
mortgage or kids or anyone depending on
your income they're gonna have to spend
some of that precious time getting life
insurance if you need life insurance but
you don't want to spend a lot of time
comparing it
you should give policy genius a try
policy genius is the easy way to buy
life insurance online in just two
minutes you can compare quotes from the
top insurers and find your best price
once you apply the policy genius team
will handle all the paperwork and red
tape no Commission's no hidden fees just
more time saved for you and policy
genius doesn't just make life insurance
easy they also make it easy to find the
right home insurance or auto insurance
or disability insurance that your one
stop shop for financial protection so if
you need life insurance but you're short
on time head on over to policy genius
calm and comparequotes policy genius is
easy it saves you time it saves you
money it is really fast you're not gonna
spend a lot of time looking for life
insurance you're just gonna get the best
price policy genius spend less time
comparing life insurance and more time
doing anything else like enjoying life
go be an adult right now make sure your
family is taken care of in case god
forbid something should happen to you go
check them out over a policy genius calm
and compare those quotes policy genius
spend
less time comparing life insurance and
save yourself some money in the process
okay so as I say there's a gap between
the old guard Democrats and the new
guard Democrats the new guard Democrats
will want Biden out and it is obvious
that they want by now because they're
using the same tactics that Democrats
have been using on Republicans against
Joe Biden the war on women meme has now
been extended to Joe Biden the
revolution eats its own and it is
fascinating to watch Democrats have been
trying since 2016 and even before in
2012 they tried it with Mitt Romney to
suggest that Mitt Romney was fighting a
war on women so when Mitt Romney said
that he had binders full of women so
that he could seek female employees to
give them better job opportunities the
left jumped on that to proclaim that
Mitt Romney the most anodyne milquetoast
human being who has ever walked this
earth was actually a terrible terrible
sexist and then of course they had more
material to go with with president
trumps they went with that with
President Trump to is a war on women
this is war on women meme and was pushed
by the media over and over and over you
can always tell who the enemy of the
progressive left is by who they are
using the war on women to target and
this is what you are seeing now being
used against Joe Biden hilariously
enough after eight years of ignoring the
fact that the guy gets handsy with
pretty much everybody so there's a piece
by a woman named Jennifer senior in the
New York Times and it's called what
we're not talking about when we talk
about Joe Biden and you're seeing the
Democrats and the left extend the
definition of the war on women from
actual harm to women to stuff that could
be perceived as harm to women because
they're broadening the war on women
specifically to take out political
opponents here's what Jennifer here's
what Jennifer senior says she says this
week it's Joe Biden's turn in the me to
barrel and like many Democrats I'm torn
about what to think
the allegations by Lucy Flores that in
2014 when she was running for lieutenant
governor of Nevada the VP touched her
shoulders and kissed the back of her
head cannot exactly be dismissed as an
outlier given that another allegation of
guerrilla nuzzling following just 72
hours later and that multiple photo
montages online suggest a similar
pattern and so we have another debate
about male decency and respect trying to
make creepiness against over-exuberant
affection hands eNOS against
glad-handing all the while remembering
that this is Joe Biden we're talking
about a retail politics guy from another
era known for armed grabs and bear hugs
he is by nature a physically expressive
fellow hug her not unfamiliar to him
these gray zone allegations are of
course still worth examining but they
are because they are salacious because
they are embodied because we can see
them I wonder if we spend more time
discussing them then another gray zone
problem that in my view is far more
pervasive and often less easily solved
with a sharp rebuke or a complaint to
human resources not being taken
seriously and here's where we go that if
you are a male and you side with Joe
Biden here it's because you're not
taking women seriously or if you are a
male who has not participated in any
form of sexual harassment if you're Mike
Pence you are guilty of not taking women
seriously so the war on women has now
been extended outward to include not
taking women seriously now what does she
mean by not taking women seriously
basically any time a woman feels like
she's not being taken seriously we're
supposed to see we're supposed to
believe that this is based on sexism the
subjective perception of the of the
alleged victim is all that matters when
you're not being taken seriously now as
a human being there are many times when
I have been not taken seriously my
employees I'm sure feel routinely not
taken seriously sorry guys but the fact
is that that does not mean they're not
being taken seriously or that that's a
crime or that sexism in some way Oh
Jennifer senora says here's the truth
some of the women I know have me two
stories but most of the women I know
have stories about feeling dismissed
invisible and less than okay but how
were they mistreated she says what are
they talking about they're talking about
seeing their ideas gain traction in a
meeting only after a man has said them
or being told after they've asserted
themselves in a meeting that they
dominated it or at the least talked too
much now we don't know any of the
context we don't know whether it's
possible that a woman in a meeting just
didn't express her ideas forcefully
enough or maybe she was too forceful it
turns out people don't like men - how
many meetings have you been in where the
guy is just a jerk where the guy is
obnoxious
that's not sexism but sometimes people
are annoying and yet there's a full
article in The New York Times
now broadening the scope of the inquiry
about Joe Biden from he's handsy and
physically aggressive with people -
sometimes women feel disrespected
personally she says has this columnist
I've been mansplain about my own book
mansplain is one of the dummer phrases
in human history man's plane this this
this pseudo term of art
when is it just explaining something to
a human and when is it man's planning
why do you have to assume bad motives on
the part of somebody who's explaining
something like legitimately I spend a
lot of my time explaining politics to
people that is not man's planning that
is me explaining explain things to my
kids sometimes I explain things to my
wife often times my wife explains things
to me like why didn't you take out the
garbage and also get up out of bed and
take out the garbage
like people get explained to a lot but
the attempt to broaden out victimhood
from originally sexual assault to now
you're being nuzzled by a weirdo too
exuberant politician to I feel man
splayed into is a pretty radical move
that is intended to divide Americans and
it's not just this this silly column
that suggests that women are constantly
being victimized in soft ways around
society as I mentioned on yesterday's
show there's a certain amount of ghost
hunting that happens on the Left where
if you feel something bad has happened
we're supposed to ascribe it to some
ghosts in the machines and some weird
societal force that we can't peg down to
particular actions but that made you
feel bad I'm big evidence fan so this is
not one of my favorite things and you're
seeing the left do this with regard to
statistics as well constantly shifting
the statistics so yesterday for example
there's an article it was equal pay day
which is a statistical why it does not
take until April seconds of the
following year for women to earn the
same as men women earn effectively the
same as men because they are because
they make different decisions about
their careers equal pay day is based on
aggregate statistics without taking into
account job choice time out of the
workforce
motherhood amount of time spent at the
office how often you ask for a raise
like there are a lot of factors when it
comes to this stuff but women are
effectively earning as much as men and
according to some studies in major
cities particularly women who are fresh
out of college in the same degrees as
men who are single and don't have kids
are earning more than men
according to one Time magazine article
from 2010 a lot more than men actually
so now the left is shifting the goal
posts because in order to divide
Americans from Americans we have to
shift the goalposts and suggest that
discrimination is still a deeply active
factor in every aspect of American life
in a second I'm going to show you how
the goal posts are changing first let's
talk about the best coffee on the market
I'm talking about black rifle
morning coffee it's an American
institution that's why when it comes to
starting my day I reach for the most
American coffee on the market black
rifle coffee black rifle coffee gives a
portion of their sales to veterans and
first responder causes black rifle
coffees rose to order guaranteeing you
fresh delicious coffee with every order
and black rifles coffee club makes
things easy you just pick your blend in
the amount you want black rifle ships
your coffee right to your door every
month hassle free The Dude's a black
rifle coffee are there great people
there's just wonderful wonderful people
ex-military
many of them are associated with
veterans causes again they still give a
portion of their sales to veteran and
first responder to causes they're a lot
of fun you can go check out all the
material online too and their coffee is
just first-rate well the left threatens
to further tax your hard-earned money
with their socialist agenda black rifle
coffee is fueling the fight for freedom
by upping their offer to 20% off your
first purchase
take advantage by visiting black rifle
coffee calm /ban receive 20% off your
first purchase that is black rifle
coffee calm /ban for 20% off your first
purchase
black rifle coffee calm slash men go
check that out right now black rifle
coffee calm slash man great dudes
fantastic coffee black rifle coffee calm
/ men go subscribe right now ok so as I
say the left in an attempt to move
beyond the old left in an attempt to
move beyond the joe biden's of the world
there now broadening out the definitions
of discrimination because one of the
fundamental signs of leftist theology
and it really is a near religion at this
point is dramatic and gratitude toward
the state of things in the United States
where even Joe Biden is not far left
enough for you I'll get some more of
that in just a second first you have to
go over and subscribe daily we're calm
$9.99 a month gets you a subscription to
daily wire when you do you get the rest
of this show live two additional hours
every day of me why would you not want
to spend that time I mean that's amazing
I'm great you love it two additional
hours and sometimes we allow you to ask
questions in the middle of the of the
radio show in the middle of the breaks
plus with the annual subscription you
get this the leftist years hot or cold
tumbler and get special access to our
Sunday specials our Sunday specials
appear for you on Saturdays and when
they happen on Saturdays you get access
to additional material this Sunday's
special this upcoming Sunday special
maybe my favorite Sunday special that
we've ever filmed we had a Democratic
presidential candidate Andrew yang
we spent the full hour as Larry King
would say with Andrew yang here's a
little bit of what it sounded like
hi I'm Andrew yang I'm running for
president in 2020 joined me on this
Sunday Sunday special where me and Ben
talk about my campaign the freedom
dividend the future of the economy and
how we can restore meaning to more
Americans around the country
okay suffice it to say I am now rooting
for Andrew yang specifically because
he's the only Democrat who's ballsy
enough to actually come on the Sunday
special we have open invites out to
every Democratic candidate some like
mayor Pete Buddha jesh have suggested
that they would be happy to come on and
then no follow-up so there's a shocker
but I would love to have mod as you'll
see from the Sunday special it is
cordial I think it's a great exchange of
ideas that is not meant to be a Ben
Shapiro destroys video that's not what
the Sunday special is it really is just
a way for people to discuss issues at a
high level so check that out it really
is a lot of fun I also go subscribe over
YouTube or iTunes and get a lot of our
content there for free and when you do
leave us a review it always helps us in
the rankings we are the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
all righty so let's talk about the
expansion of definitions so as to rule
out the old school left I talked
yesterday about the attempt by the left
to move beyond the Obama era Obama is
the old and in with the new
we need a OC we need Bernie Sanders we
need extremism and earlier in the show I
talked a little bit about the fact that
this is actually a large mistake by
Democrats that if Democrats believe that
they're going to win swing states by
swinging wildly to left they're wrong
but Democrats are trying to recapitulate
Obama's 2012 win not his 2008 win in
2008 Obama ran on the platform that we
are all brothers and sisters there's no
red states there's no blue slits there's
legal sites and that was attractive and
then in 2012 Obama said well turns out I
was wrong
there are some red states and there are
some blue states and mostly there are a
lot of victim groups and if we can get
those people together and they can vote
for me well that's a durable coalition
and that turned out to be the democratic
model well now they're trying to rebuild
that coalition along the lines of a
victimhood that is certainly not in
evidence particularly with regard to sex
so they've continued to push this war on
women meme and suggest that suburban
women should vote for them because they
recognize the problems of women and so
they're now looking at Joe Biden and
saying this guy's old school he's bad
with women bad with women he's been this
way his entire career guys and it ain't
that bad lately should be frank about
this his behavior is not all that
terrible is it something that I would do
no I am NOT a physically forward person
the way that yo Biden is I have
boundaries Joe Biden has none but are we
gonna pretend the Democrats were unaware
of all of this for years with Joe Biden
and now they've expanded the definition
out from he's not actually none of these
women alleged sexual harassment by the
way so they are they're not saying he
even sexually harassed them they're
saying they felt uncomfortable because
of something they did and now you have
an article in The Washington Post
suggesting it's not just that we felt
uncomfortable it's that we feel
disrespected by a variety of issues and
now you have the Washington Post doing
this on the economic front suggesting
that the problem is not equal pay
because equal pay basically exists now
it is unequal wealth so they are now
shifting the standards to pretend that
America is still systemically
discriminating against women for
purposes of suggesting that people like
Joe Biden are too old-school say if
people
jannis travel itand robert wright
writing articles for the washington post
called america doesn't just have a
gender pay gap it has a gender wealth
gap they say April second is equal pay
day which reminds employees everywhere
how much progress remains too close the
gender pay gap okay first of all that is
a lie
that is simply a lie women are not
earning dramatically less than men but
then they expand the definition because
they understand secretly a lot of
members of the media that equal pay day
is a bunch of crap so instead they
expand the definition you've seen this
happen also with regard to wealth
differentials among communities racial
communities so instead of talking about
income mobility and the possibility of
income mobility if you make good
decisions in your life instead what the
media will talk about is the wealth gap
so this is what they're doing with women
now they're saying it's not just the pay
gap that should concern women it is also
the wealth gap on average women in the
United States owned a mere thirty two
cents to every dollar owned by men now
first of all if women are married to men
they have precise in community property
states they own precisely the same
amount of dollars as men do they have
exactly the same wealth as my wife and I
have the same wealth my earning power is
a lot higher than my wife's earning
power it doesn't matter we have exactly
the same amount of wealth it's community
property state we have a joint bank
account we own our house jointly this is
this is silly this is silly but beyond
that what this is really an attempt to
do is suggest that because women were
historically discriminated against
therefore they are currently
discriminated against that is not an
argument that is a leap in logic just
because something bad was true 50 years
ago does not mean that same bad thing is
true today even if the impact of the bad
thing fifty years ago is still felt
today and things like racial wealth gaps
or sexual wealth gaps but there's an
attempt to paint America is deeply
unjust as deeply unequal that requires
radical solutions this is the direction
the Democratic Party wishes to move
they're looking for they're looking for
soft ways that they can sense
discrimination soft ways that they can
create victim classes I mean all the way
down to leggings there's an article in
The New York Times a full article in the
Style section of the New York Times
about why are men and and some women so
upset about people wearing leggings in
public it must be sexism or
alternatively they're just not a huge
fan of people wearing clothing that is
effectively tight in public because that
doesn't seem either modest
prudent are we supposed to pretend that
if you just walked around naked in broad
daylight that that would be the same
thing as if you were burqa in broad
daylight like clothing does seem to
matter a little bit and how we perceive
people which is why police officers and
doctors wear uniforms but all of this is
supposed to be a soft form of sexism the
the continued breaking down of Americans
into victim groups is one of the chief
core tenants of the modern Democratic
Party which is why for example I think
the peabody judge is in trouble
PBOT a judge who is a gay man in America
does not make a point of him being a
victim he doesn't he doesn't try to say
I'm a victim in America his book which
is actually pretty interesting he
doesn't make a huge deal out of this
idea that I'm gay therefore I'm a
massive victim of discrimination in the
United States he's the mayor of South
Bend Indiana right I mean it's not
exactly great evidence that people hate
you that the person who was just elected
the mayor of Chicago is a black lesbian
and this is not a country where
discrimination is is a wildly prevalent
everyday deep-seated occurrence that is
causing mass disparity is possible that
disparities are caused by other factors
but the Democratic Party is banking on a
feeling of dispossession in order for
them to regain power
now listen President Trump did this in
Reverse in 2016 he suggested there's a
vast swath of people across the country
feeling dispossessed with the current
political system who have been
effectively ignored and disparaged by
Barack Obama and Hillary Clinton didn't
call deplorable 'he's been told that
they are somehow inferior or lesser or
they are racist bigoted sexist
homophobes and all the rest and those
are the people I'm gonna speak to well
Democrats are doing the same thing and
have been doing the same thing for years
trying to identify victim groups and
then broadening the definition of
victimhood in order to make excuses for
why obviously non victim groups are
actually
victim groups and then suggesting that
candidates they don't like are the
victimizers Joe Biden has found himself
in the crosshairs because of this he
does not mesh with the current
priorities of the Democratic Party and
thus he's in the victimizer class and
you're starting to see this from the
left about but a judge they got him
about Buddha judges it's pretty amazing
he's the p's part of the victimizer
class - now the person who's been able
to escape all of this of course is
Bernie Sanders he's not part of the
victimizer class why because despite the
fact that the Bernie bros were not
exactly great with the ladies and
despite the fact that Bernie
Anders has had some racial issues in
some of the statements Bernie Sanders is
wildly perceived and widely perceived as
in extreme leftist so that means that we
can rule him in as opposed to ruling him
out it is pretty impressive to watch as
the Democrats prepare to shoot
themselves in the feet providing the the
impetus for president Trump's 2020
campaign this is all President Trump
wants for his birthday man is for the
Democrats to do exactly this
so yesterday President Trump spoke at
the NRCC
and you can see this is going to be his
angle in 2020 as well it should be here
is President Trump going after the green
New Deal and pointing out if he loses to
this he deserves to lose the green new
deal done by a young bartender 29 years
old a young bartender wonderful young
woman the green New Deal you know but
it's crazy you know the first time I
heard I said that's the craziest thing
you have senators that are professionals
that you guys know that have been there
for a long time white hair everything
perfect and they're standing behind her
in there shaking they're petrified of
her we support the green dude deal okay
he is totally right about all of this of
course and you know he's gonna get flat
for saying oh my god she's demeaning her
as a bartender no he's saying she
doesn't have any expertise in the area
in which she professes expertise which
is obviously true and then Trump in
actual coherent fashion goes after
socialism in the Democratic Party they
are making it easy for him it's amazing
I've never seen a party owned itself so
hard as the Democrats are doing
currently don't underestimate the power
of socialism to get a vote it's what
happens over a 10-year period when the
country is destroyed but they don't care
about that when they say we're going to
give you free education we're going to
give you free healthcare we're going to
not have you pay your loans for college
we're going to give you free everything
everything is free it's very seductive
to people it's not going to be so easy
like you think now in ten years it's
going to be easy when the country goes
to hell so we have to work we can never
take it for granted we have to explain
how bad it
hey and he is not wrong about any of
this and Democrats are providing him
room to run because they're either
delusional delusionally hopeful or
delusionally angry now they do have one
hope and that is that the media will
somehow save them because the media have
done yeoman's work on behalf of
Democrats for legitimately years the
best example of this came yesterday when
cnn's cnn's christina I'm on por for
some reason is considered an objective
journalist she decides to journalism all
over all over James Comey here she is
explaining that lock her up is hate
speech and maybe the FBI should have
investigated and jailed people over it
of course lock her up was a feature of
the 2016 Trump campaign do you in
retrospect wish that people like
yourself the head of the FBI I mean the
people in charge of law and order had
shut down that language that it was
dangerous potentially that it could have
created violence that is kind of hate
speech should that have been allowed
that's not a role for government to play
the beauty of this country is people can
say what they want even if it's
misleading and and it's demagoguery the
people should have shut it down
Republicans and the point is not James
commis response here which is basically
correct it is the fact that Christiane
Amanpour is considered some sort of
objective journalist or how about the
ladies of the view who ripped on Meghan
McCain yesterday Meghan McCain said yeah
Obama had some scandals and all the
ladies of the view were like he never
had a scandal he was the best
Obama he was so great he never had a
scandal at all it must be great to be a
Democrat honestly people say if this was
Obama nothing like this even remotely
close ever happened in that
administration but you know I believe
scandal for I think this candle can you
risk it
but I don't want to do this with you
this morning I think the problem is when
you put the Obama administration up as
this this pristine scandal free perfect
administration that never did anything
wrong for conservatives and Republicans
there were a lot of politics that were
pretty into glaze 3 but I'm saying there
was a lot of policies put into place
that rational conservatives disagreed
with and I think part of the problem is
feels very judgmental if you didn't like
the Obama administration and you have a
problem with the Iran deal that's how
you got Trump
okay and she is right about this it is
also true that they were
scandal-free what they living hell the
IRS under Barack Obama targeted opposing
501c3 groups
Eric Holder was held in contempt by
Congress over fast and furious and
Barack Obama asserted executive
privilege to protect him Barack Obama
said openly on an open mic to the to the
Russians that he would provide them
flexibility after the election if they
would lay off before the election Barack
Obama scandal-free it is so highly
irritating to hear that nonsense over
and over from our great protectors the
firefighters who protect us how about
Good Morning America they're doing the
same thing they invited on Valerie
Jarrett who presided over the scandal
filled Obama administration to talk
about how terrible Trump was I mean it's
just an open invite to Valerie Jarrett
abash Trump I think the political
landscape today in some ways is
depressing I think tone does start at
the top we look to the president the
United States to be the leader to be a
role model particularly for young people
and I I think as some of the rhetoric
has been profoundly disappointing and
troubling to me he was very much a part
of the birther controversy what would
that be the driving force behind the
birther controversy
I think it's unconscionable and I think
it you know it incited hatred and I
think it put President Obama and his
family in harm's way
okay so again it is it is fun to watch
the media simply play defense for every
Democrat there's a reason all the top
Democrats in Virginia are still holding
their offices it's also amazing that the
media continue to pretend they're
objective when they're obviously not
Dean Baquet who's the publisher of the
New York Times he said yesterday that we
are happy to publish all sorts of
perspectives like they literally
published a full on 12,000 words screed
on why Israel should be boycotted by
somebody who's paid in part by the
government of Qatar a terror supporting
state that was fine but they will never
print apparently any opinion that
questions the science behind global
warming despite the fact that a lot of
the modeling has been incorrect so far
and this is coming from somebody by the
way who is not a global warming skeptic
I think that anthropogenic global
warming is a thing I think that human
activity has an effect on the climate
but I am happy to hear more about
various sides of the debate but
according to the New York Times you're
not allowed to even publish that stuff
but these are the objective journalists
I'm not sure both Sider ism is
is the right approach and it's not the
approach I believe in I don't I think
that's become sort of a stalking horse
for fairness fairness mean fairness and
open-mindedness and a sense of inquiry
that to me is journalism that does not
mean if you we do not go out to make
sure we quote 25 people let's say
there's no man did not contribute to the
changing climate that would be
ridiculous that's not what most people
believe there's a debate the only debate
is what should be done about it
I don't believe in that I believe in
open mindedness open minded inquiry open
minded inquiry is what he believes in
not anyone who disagrees with him on
fundamental issues that that's that's
her media right there I love that we
don't believe in but and if if you say
well maybe you should get another
opinion
well that's both sigh tourism open
minded inquiry is where I interview
people who agree with me and we just
disagree about how strongly to agree
with me your media in a nutshell Dean
Baquet over to the New York Times okay
time for a thing that I like so there is
as I say I've been signing a lot of
books lately and because I sign a lot of
books that means that I am watching TV
while I sign those books well there
there are some movies that have become
available on Amazon for rent that kind
of fell through the cracks and are
pretty good there's a movie called
prospect with Pedro Pascal who has
become one of my favorite actors he's
really terrific he's in triple frontier
you'll also remember him from Game of
Thrones
he is quite versatile and and a girl
named Sophie Thatcher and it essentially
is a space Western I believe that this
this I'm pretty certain that the people
who wrote the movie prospect we're
basing it on Treasure Island because
it's it pretty much follows all the
beats of Treasure Island but the movie
is a good tight like hour and 30 hour
and 40 minute movie and it's about a
little girl who lands with her father on
this on this planet where there's a
natural resource that people are seeking
to extract and she's confronted by
effectively a pirate name who's played
by Pedro Pascal there's a little bit of
the preview to requesting release
I'm here to harvest I have the location
of a massive deposit of aurillac the
Queen's lair about my estimation is the
largest anyone's ever seen someone is
approaching where are you from nowhere
how poetic
the Queen's lair
okay so the movie is that the movie is
good and again it's very tight movie
it's only 97 minutes which I said
yesterday that I'm a big fan of shorter
movies it's not a special effects based
sci-fi movie it's it's a space Western
kind of and in the movie is is worth
watching so you can go check that out
I believe it's available at Amazon for
rent right now and the movie is called
prospect okay some things that I hate
okay the thing that I hate number one
why is it that online is where we find
all of the weird quasi solutions to
people's problems
and when I say solutions I mean no one
in their right mind would do these
things but we are supposed to pretend
that like they're a thing
well Vaca t'v is apparently one of the
places you go for this sort of stuff and
they have a story today about adults who
want to be swaddled in a fake womb to be
comforted I I have nothing for you here
if you can't see the video it's
legitimately people who are being tight
it says this Japanese therapy is
supposed to beat stress by taking you
back to the womb they legitimately wrap
people like Frodo is wrapped in
spiderweb at the end of Return of the
King it's supposed to recreate safety of
the womb babies feel when they're being
swaddled okay quick note never swaddle a
baby by putting the blanket over the
baby's head you don't I mean the swaddle
is supposed to go apparently over the
entire adult I remembered it wasn't this
tried by the way in the United States
there was this theory that this would be
tried in psychiatrist office a couple
people have died because of it if I'm
not mistaken and they tried this it was
like a weird therapy
thing and people would actually like
suffocate in the blanket and all of this
man people are people are dumb
does humanity deserves to survive open
question and other things that I that I
hate today so there's an amazing story
today from the BBC it just broke a
couple of hours ago
and it talks about a quote-unquote magic
bullet carbon solution to climate change
here is the article a technology that
removes carbon dioxide from the air has
received significant backing from major
fossil fuel companies British Columbia
based Carbon engineering has shown it
can extract co2 in a cost-effective way
it has now been boosted by 68 million
dollars in new investment from Chevron
Occident Occidental and coal giant bhp
campaign climate campaigners are worried
that the technology will be used to
extract even more oil why because if we
can suck these the carbon emissions out
of the air then we might continue to use
oil but then why are you whining about
us using the oil if there are no carbon
emissions because we're sucking it out
of the air I'm confused
the quest for technology for carbon
dioxide removal from the air received
significant science endorsement last
year with the publication of the IPCC
report on keeping the rise in global
temperatures to 1.5 degrees Celsius this
century in their summary for policy
makers the scientists said all pathways
that limit global warming should be
pursued effectively carbon engineering
says that it's direct air capture
process is now able to capture gas for
under $100 a ton with its new funding
the company plans to build its first
commercial facilities these industrial
scale plans could capture up to 1
million tons of co2 from the air each
year so how is it that this works well
apparently the comparatively low
concentrations of co2 in the air make it
difficult to design efficient machines
to remove the gas but carbon engineering
has a process that sucks in the air and
then exposes it to a chemical solution
that concentrates the co2 further
refinements mean that the gas can be
purified in a form that can be stored or
utilized as liquid fuel there's
basically complicated chemistry and
they're talking about making a liquid
fuel directly from co2 so instead of
having these massive emissions you are
instead using the using the carbon
dioxide to make new fuel so they take
fuel that they take the carbon emissions
in the air they suck it out of the air
and then they are recycling the carbon
emissions effectively speaking there
investing in this process because they
don't want to be regulated presumably
because this is called a market solution
and the left is opposed to it
environmentalists are angry why well
they think that it's some are worried
think that it's good but but sapore
berman international program director
for stands on earth told BBC news it's a
huge concern because they're worried
that it will prolong the fossil fuel era
but again why are you upset about the
fossil fuel era if it's not actually
going to wreck the earth anymore so the
it suggests that there's an ulterior
motive that is the thing i hate not the
technology which is great the thing I
hate is the ulterior motive if I give
you technology that will help you solve
the climate change issue say nuclear
technology or sucking the carbon out of
the air then why exactly would you
oppose it unless you have some sort of
ulterior motive which does suggest that
there's something else going on for a
lot of climate change forward-thinking
politicians that has more to do with
economic redistribution ISM than it has
to do with actually solving a problem
alrighty well we will be back here a
little bit later today for two
additional hours also I'm on Joe Rogan's
show today so you might want to go check
that out because that's a lot of fun and
in the meantime go buy my book the right
side of history which charted number
three on Amazon in nonfiction this week
and number three at Barnes & Noble as
well this week continues to sell like
hotcakes
you can be part of the movement check it
out the right side of history we will
see you here though later today if you
subscribe or tomorrow if not see you
then I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
[Music]
this is the Ben Shapiro show executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Adam Tsai
Yvette's audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright day Lee Weyer 2019
hey everybody its Andrew Klavan host of
the Andrew Clavin show the Russian
collusion hoax has collapsed the
economy's doing well but Donald Trump's
approval ratings are stuck
why can't president the Donald get some
love we'll talk about it on the Andrew
Clavin show I'm Andrew Clavin